fueras
cosas del riego bueno tenemos la remera
está la remera que usó el equipo de boca
cuando en homenaje al de aquel falleció
germanio anas es un verdadero apasionado
de diego maradona monedita la terraza
que acá tengo hecho
este montaje al mural ese amor por la
figura de maradona nació cuando lo
conoció en un viaje y luego lo
reencontró en buenos aires el mep
enfatizó mi sentir como y sentí el amigo
de él compartirlo en ti dicho cuando lo
volví a ver me reconoció y siempre se
tomó fotos con él son una especie de
trofeo para los fanáticos del futbolista
porque tampoco era fácil llegar ahora
porque todo el mundo quiere estar con
maradona no sé creo que hizo lo que lo
hace tener una foto en ese momento sin
haber llegado al lado de él yo tuve la
suerte de haber llegado y haber
compartido con él el envió las suyas a
una iniciativa que recolecta fotos
personales con maradona se llama
proyecto pelusa por el apodo de infancia
del futbolista y funciona sobre una
página de instagram y la idea del
proyecto pelusa en general es una
biografía popular y colaborativa sobre
la vida de diego maradona a través de
los ojos de la gente a través de las
fotos que se sacó con la gente a lo
largo de toda su vida para el proyecto
lo esencial es la combinación de la foto
y la historia que la acompaña como la
deva pardo fotógrafa de gimnasia y
esgrima de la plata el último club en el
que como técnico estuvo maradona está
secuencia que está en proyecto pelusa se
la tomaron cuando ella lo retrato tras
una victoria del club les dejamos nos
abrazamos con cena
del triunfo hasta el abrazo con él
y esta es la última foto que le saco a
maradona no se siento que es
una foto que yo ya tenía en mente o sea
que era de la forma que a mí
me gustaba retratar lo una de las
últimas fotos de una biografía infinita
y compleja hecha de memoria colectiva